animals kill on average more than 400
people in the United States each year
and the deadliest of them all live a lot
closer to you than you might think this
is where mountain lions roam they're
considered one of the most powerful
predators on the planet but they pose
little threat to humans killing about
one person every five to ten years
they're far more likely to go after prey
like deer or raccoons but when it comes
to killing size isn't everything there
are more than 70 species of scorpion
across the u.s. and together they kill
an average of one person about every two
and a half years but none are more
dangerous than the Arizona bark scorpion
which lives primarily in Arizona and New
Mexico it's one of 30 species worldwide
that produces venom toxic enough to be
fatal
next up is perhaps the most notorious of
killers sharks between 2007 and 2008
teen there were 920 shark attacks
worldwide and more than half of them
were in US waters but thankfully most
shark attacks aren't fatal and on
average sharks kill Americans just once
every 1.7 years and actually there's
another water-loving predator that's
more deadly these two Theory pals range
from Texas to North Carolina and kill
about one person every year and a half
most famously a young boy who was
playing near a pond at the Disney World
Hotel in 2016 but even alligators and
crocodiles are not as deadly as bears in
one color or another bears range from
Alaska down through much of the forested
United States they kill about one to two
people a year and nearly half of all
fatal wild bear attacks since 1900
occurred in one of these six parks but
even seventeen hundred pound bears have
nothing on spiders which taken
altogether kill around seven people a
year most of these deaths are likely
linked to just two spiders the Black
Widow
and the brown recluse that's because
they're the only two spiders in the US
with venom that's toxic to humans you
can find black widows throughout the US
and the brown recluse is native to the
Midwest and the south these spiders live
in basements abandoned shoes and outside
in piles of rocks and wood and you know
what else you can find there snakes the
US has about 20 species of venomous
snakes which live in every state except
Alaska copperheads are the most likely
to bite you and live in the southeastern
United States but you should be most
aware of rattlesnakes like the eastern
and western diamondback which are
responsible for the most snake related
deaths on average snakes kill as many as
10 to 15 people a year oh and if you
really hate snakes
here are the states with the highest
bitrates that you'd definitely want to
avoid now if there's anything scarier
than bears spiders and snakes it's cows
that's right each year cows kill about
20 people typically by kicking or
trampling and about three-quarters of
those incidents are reportedly
deliberate attacks of course you can
find cows everywhere and the same goes
for the top three animals on our list
dogs kill about 30 people a year most
often from attacks that prove fatal and
pit bulls are responsible for more than
half of them bees and other stinging
insects kill nearly a hundred people per
year often by triggering an allergic
reaction one kind often called The
Killer Bee is especially aggressive if
disturbed they'll swarm and can sting
victims more than 1,000 times and last
but not least at the top of our list is
an animal that isn't toxic and doesn't
generally attack humans deer each year
deer caused about 1.3 million car
accidents and about 200 of them are
fatal
your risk is much higher in some states
like West Virginia but taken altogether
your odds of dying from any kind of
animal running are slim and when you
compare that to the leading causes of
death in America you'll realize that
animals are the least of your worries
[Music]